it's again a real pleasure to have um
italia right
speaking to us um itai um
also you know he he did his uh phd in
physics
and uh um and
you know worked for a while in astronomy
before he saw the light and
and moved to to quantum computation
i i think he's um you know um
he was a postdoc initially with um gary
daranov and then then at berkeley
and ever since those days he's been
singularly focused on this issue of
area laws and i i think i can say that i
know if nobody who is
taught as long as and deeply about this
this subject as etai so um
again it's a real pleasure to have you
here and talk talk
about it okay thank you very much
um thanks for for inviting me um
okay let me first uh can i share the
screen now um
is it is it okay yeah it looks great
okay
okay so thanks again and thank you that
was very
clear talk uh i'm i wish
uh you set a very high bar for
you know for the level of clarity i'm
not sure i'm going to
approach it but um in any case um
i'm going to talk today about about area
laws in
metabolic quantum physics and um
why i think they're interesting and and
some of the of the techniques and
insight that
can be gained by by starting uh by
starting uh
these things um okay so um
so the talk will have roughly like four
parts
um in the first part i will uh i will
introduce what an aerial law is and
why it is interesting and i will repeat
some of the things that they've said
about the official description of
many body quantum states and why do we
care about area laws when we talk about
uh
simulations and then um in the next part
i will
describe one particular approach for uh
for establishing
area laws which is called the the
approximate ground state projector
uh framework and i will define what what
these
these objects are and why they are i'll
try to explain why they are helpful in
trying to establish area laws and
then i will apply this framework and i
will show
one particular application of that for
the for the case of 1d
systems and i will show i will
demonstrate how
it works and then um time permitting i
will i will try also to um
to sketch the the construction of of uh
of such a gsb also for the 2d case it's
a very recently sold together with uh
and david cassette and um
that that gives an aerial law for a for
a particular subset of uh 2d systems
yeah so and and
just like that said um any any questions
i'll be
very glad to to answer and
it's good if with the last question even
if i get stuck in the middle of my talk
okay um
okay so let me just
move this here okay um
okay so um the subject that i'm talking
about is
uh for the the the setup is is made by
the quantum systems
um so
we usually in in in in many body physics
we consider usually
and and spins or cubits um
there are and we assume that they are
sitting on some
d-dimensional lattice this is a very
common uh model for uh
in condensed matter physics and um
the hilbert space of the entire system
is of course the tensors
the tensor product of the hyperspaces of
the single particles
here i i focused on qubits where the
the local dimension is two but i will
later switch to general d dimensional
particles and um
the dimension of the entire space then
is is is 2 to the n
this is the tensor product of these
local dimensions and
like like that mentioned we can we can
uh define
uh the main object of the stock is is is
local hamiltonian
this is a an emission operator that
encodes interaction
uh between these different uh particles
and we write it as a sum of
of terms of hi each one of them is a
it's an emission operator
and it acts locally uh on
two neighboring particles it's full so
for example
in this in this picture it will be uh
there will be a time here and the time
here
et cetera et cetera um
so these are these are the this is the
main object that uh that i'm going to
discuss
and uh the state of the system of course
like i've said
is a is a vector in this uh huge
hilbert space and to describe it if we
want to describe it fully we have to
specify
all the coordinates of all possible
bases so for example
if we have a system of four qubits we
need like
16 16 complex numbers in order to
fully specify the the state of the
system
okay so um so what are the main problem
the main
problem that we are trying to solve here
so the main problem is
is to understand these systems and this
is a very hard problem because of the
underlying exponentiality of this this
uh
this problem um
so one thing we would like to be able to
do
and uh is um is for example to
uh to understand the time evolution of
the system there is a missing sorry
there is a missing
imaginary eye here so time evolution is
to solve the time solution of the system
we need to solve the schrodinger
equation and if we know the hamiltonian
of the system then it would be
uh the state if we know the state of the
system at time zero the stated system at
time t will be given to us by by this
formula
and this is again this is a linear
formula in a
matrix multiplication multiplication
of of a exponential tensor in a
with an exponential matrix so it's a
very hard problem
and another place where h comes into
picture
is uh when we describe the thermal
equilibrium state of the system
if we take our system and we attach it
into a heat path temperature to t
then we know that the state of the
system is is described
when the system reaches equilibrium is
described by this exponential matrix of
2 to the n input to the end it is called
the gibbs state
system and z here is is just a
normalization
constant and if you want to understand
the properties
of the system at equilibrium temperature
t
then we need to understand the structure
of this of this huge matrix
for example what we what we will be
interested in
is understanding for example the
expectation value of some local
observable
so imagine we have some operator a which
corresponds to
some observable defined on these two
neighboring particles it could be
the energy interaction between these two
it could be
i know average magnetization etc
so this is an operator which is
non-trivial
in the space of these two particles and
then it is
tensor with the identity on the rest of
the system what we would like to
understand is
what it is what is its expectation value
and if we have uh
if we're doing the time evolution system
then it will be this expression and if
we are doing
if we we have the equilibrium state then
it will be that expression
in both cases again because the
underlying matrices are exponential this
is these
these things are on the surface at least
are very very hard problems for us
to solve
okay so um why do we care about the
ground state
um the reason why we care about ground
state usually
is because ground state are described
the system uh
or a good approximation to the system
when the temperature of the syst
of the system goes uh goes to zero
uh if the recall that the
the gibbs system is is given by this
formula if
if we now write this this operator here
uh in its diagonalizing basis
we will get this uh this expression here
and now if we let
t goes to zero then we see that all the
all the different contributions from all
eigenstates of
of h will will die off and we will be
left with the
uh the dominant contribution which is
the contribution of the
uh of the eigenstate with the lowest
with the lowest energy and this is why
when
the temperature goes to zero the
the gibbs state of the systems the state
of the system at the equilibrium
reaches uh reaches the ground state and
and therefore
um if we want to understand the physics
of the system at low temperature
then we better understand the structure
of the of the ground state
so we can now uh
having having said that then uh we can
now
uh phrase this problem as a problem of
if we want to understand
of understanding um the global minimum
which is the this eigenstate of of a
system
uh of a local quantum
constraint this is what uh what said
because we can also write the the ground
state as the
uh as the minimal as a state that gives
the minimal
expectation value of this of this of
this
operator and in other words
what we are looking for is we are
looking for a state upside that
minimizes
all the all the this sum of of local of
local terms and
in view of the of the of the csp
and hamiltonian correspondence this can
be viewed as we are looking for
the quantum assignment that minimizes
the number of violations
so this thing here will be the
violations of uh
of of a global system where all the
violations are given by
uh violations of local constraints
okay so now we might ask ourselves how
hard is it
to approximate the ground state of a
many-body
quantum system formally we can we can we
can uh
we can write this as a as a following
problem given
some local hamiltonian on some lattice
on some graph
then um what is the hardness of
approximating the ground energy of this
of this uh
of this system to within say one over
poly where
poly poly end is where n is the size of
the system the number of
particles so generally this is uh
this is known to be a very hard problem
it is in fact a quantum
np-hard problem or a qma as was shown by
guitar in in 98 essentially what it
means it means that
in order to to solve this problem
this problem can be can be can be very
can be
verified using using a a quantum
weakness
so if you have a quantum computer then
if you
then then you know you can you can
verify that a certain that the certain
state is indeed
the ground state by simply by measuring
its energy and then
and then seeing that indeed uh this
energy is below a certain threshold or
not so
so in in in general this problem has
changed
this is what kitab show this problem is
is uh
is extremely hard it is believed to be
harder than np problems because
quantum and the class of quantum and
peace is uh
is believed to be um much
much bigger than the regular np however
sometimes um for certain classes of
problems and this is
the classes that i will try to talk
about
in in this colloquium this problem might
be easier sometimes
the the problem of of approximating the
ground energy or approximating the
ground state itself
can be uh within p or within np
and one place and one reason why this
can
this can happen is when we have a
classical representation of
of the ground state instead of a quantum
representation if we have a classical
representation and we can
manipulate this representation
efficiently in a classical computer
then we can uh
then maybe this problem is inside np
because this classical representation
can be the witness
uh and and can be the proof or for
certain properties
of that system okay
okay so what is an efficient
representation
um so this is something that zeph has
already uh
mentioned so generally we have no hope
of having an efficient classical
representation of
anybody quantum state and the reason is
that generally if we have a
state of over n and spins or n qubits
then
its general state should be written like
that and this is a collection
of two to the n complex coefficients and
of course we don't have enough memory in
any computer
just to store this this thing so
however so but it can be it can happen
but for certain classes of states there
is there
there exists some some efficient
representation of of
these states and and this is exactly
what we mean by efficient representation
we we actually demand the following two
properties
the first property would be that we
would be able to
store or approximate this
or approximate or store the psi or
some sort of an approximate description
of psi using only a polynomial
number of parameters instead of this
exponential number of parameters so
that's one requirement for
a representation to be uh efficient
the other not less important property is
that we demanded this
way of of storing the information will
also be useful for us
in other words what we actually demand
is that we can use take this
representation
and efficiently use it in order to
approximate
local expectation values of that state
in other words we can use this
representation to do calculations
and to to know things about
about the the overall system so
so this is these two requirements uh
represent what uh
an efficient representation is and um
and one way in which one one roots
in which we can proceed in order to find
efficient representations of
of of many body quantum state is by
bounding
the amount of entanglement inside these
states
so
so why why um
why do we need to bound the the amount
of entanglement or
why does it help us to bound the amount
of entanglement so first of all
let me just um remind you that
entitlement
is it can be viewed as some sort of
of a quantum correlation it's a
correlation between the different
quantum particles quantum degrees of
freedom
and to demonstrate why
having a bound on the entanglement might
be helpful for
finding an efficient representation
let's look at two
very extreme cases in the one case
we have let's look at the system of n
particles but let's assume that all
these particles are unentangled to each
other
and the overall state of the system is a
product state okay in such
in such case psi the overall state of
the system can be written like this
and because each one of these psi i is a
is a is a state in a local hilbert space
then it can be
represented by uh
sorry it can be represented by
a very uh a very small number of uh
of parameters so in order to fully
specify the
uh the state of time we only need n such
uh such uh we only need to specify
and such psi so overall
the number of parameters that we need is
only linear in the system size
on the other hand as we just saw if we
have a fully uh entitled state then in
general
we have this superposition of an
exponential number of states
and we will need something of the order
of two to the n parameters
just to uh to specify them
okay so
so one way uh so
one way to to find an efficient
representation is by bounding the
entitlement
and to bound the entanglement then one
way to do it
is by establishing an area law so what
is
what is what are area laws so area laws
are some sort of
bound on the amount of entitlement that
there is in the system
so imagine um a system of particles that
sit on some lattice
and um let us look at the bipartition of
the system into some region l
and its exterior lc now
for any uh any state for any state in
that system say
state psi we can always write it as a
superposition
of states that are defined inside l
these are the i alpha inside and
time state that are defined outside of l
this is the o
alpha and we can also do it in a
canonical way which is called the
uh the schmidt decomposition and the
schmidty composition is actually
uh the way that uses the minimal number
of such
of such product states
now uh when we when we do when we write
it this way then also the
one one of the properties of the 20
composition is that these um
these weights here this lambda alpha if
we sum if we take the square of them
they sum up to one so we can
we can look at them as a as a some sort
of a probability distribution
and using this probability this
distribution if we look at
its channel entropy then this define
defines us
the entanglement entropy between uh
between l and its exterior part so
so um by having for example a flat
distribution
then this means that we actually have a
lot of of uh
we we have a lot of uh uh
our superposition consists of a lot of
product states between
uh the inside and the outside that means
that there is a lot of entanglement
on the other hand if we just have a
product state then this
we will have only a single lambda and it
will be equal to one and then we have a
sharp
probability distribution and as a result
the entire element entropy will be equal
to
zero okay so entanglement entropy is
some sort of
some sort of a measure just like the the
number of of
these product states that measures how
much
entanglement there exists between the
inside and the outside
and an area law is a situation in which
for every party by partition of the
system into l and lc
we have that the uh entanglement entropy
scales like the size of the boundary
between these two things instead of the
more general
more general situation in which uh it
scales like the volume of l
if we take a random state and we will
calculate its entanglement entropy we
will see that
it will scale just like the volume of l
but
in a very in very special situation this
is the
for very specific state we can uh
the there are there will be some states
for which the entitlement entropy will
scale like the boundary
and the intuition of why these things
happen is that
because entanglement is it is in can be
viewed as some sort of correlation
between quantum degrees of freedom
then uh having an aerial law is some
sort of a hallmark of locality
what it means is what we're some sort of
a toy picture
to to view is that all the all the
correlation in the system are short
range and as a result if we are
if the entitlement between l and l and
the exterior of l measures the amount of
correlation between the degrees of
freedom here and the degrees of freedom
outside
then only the degrees of freedom of l
that are near the boundary will be
entangled with the degrees of freedom
of the outside part and as a result the
amount of entitlement will be
proportional to the size
of the of the boundary on the other end
when the uh
when the correlation are long range and
there is all sorts of entitlements
all sorts of length scales then we
expect that
different points inside inside the bulk
of l will be
entangled with different points in the
bulk of lc
and as a result the amount of
rectangular men
should scale like the part of l the
volume of l instead of
of the of the boundary so so
area laws can be viewed in some sense as
a sign of locality
in the system are there any questions or
okay
[Applause]
okay so um
so now that i've defined the area law
let me now state what is the conjecture
what is the area low conjecture
and the aerial conjecture states that
ground states of local hamiltonian under
certain conditions
satisfy an arrow and this is a this is a
very strong
conjecture because it tells us that the
dynamic entropy
in certain ground states of of many
valid quantum system is very very
restricted
and that all will will imply in some
sense that
uh it might imply that there exists some
sort of
an efficient description of these of
these of these states
so specifically what what what is the uh
what is the assumption that we are
making here so first of all
we will we are talking about local
hamiltonians that are defined on
some well-structured d-dimensional uh
lattice so it can be three dimensional
lattice like hiddes or
two-dimensional one-dimensional and we
assume that the interactions are
between nearest neighbors just like i
i drew here in this picture this is the
first assumption that
that that i'm assuming and the second
assumption is something
might look strange in the beginning it's
assumption about
the eigenvalues of this operator h or
the
eigen energies of the of the system what
i demand i demand that
there is a gap between the lowest eigen
value
of h which is called the ground energy
and the first and the first eigenvalue
that comes above it which is called the
first excited energy
and we define this gap to be
uh epsilon to be the difference between
uh these two energies
and the area law conjecture states that
whenever we have
a large gap so whenever the gap the
difference between these two energies
um is of order one and
and the overall hamiltonian is has this
property so it is a
short range sitting on the ladders et
cetera then the conjecture states that
uh the ground state of that system
should satisfy
the law so can i ask a question yes sir
when you say that it's ordered one you
mean it's lower bounded by a constant or
it's upper bounded by a constant
it is lower bounded by a constant oh you
see this so this is what a cs person
would write this
oh yeah yeah sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're right it should be an omega
yeah okay thanks yeah um so while we are
clarifying uh
itai did you mean delta times epsilon or
you meant something else that did you
just mean delta or
uh i just meant delta yeah it's a typo
that is yeah
okay um
so um so why do we think that this uh
uh that this conjecture is true
so here is one intuition i like
large gap large spectral gap it implies
a fast convergence
to the ground state and therefore it
implies
that the grass that has a weak
correlation and as a result it doesn't
have
a lot of entanglement so specifically
one one way to
to view it is that we can look at this
operator this
this what this operator here will do is
that it will um
it will it will scale every
every eigen state of the hamiltonian
with uh with one minus the energy
of that of that of that eigenstate
divided by the overall norm of the
system and as a result
uh this operator will if we if we if we
apply
l times it will take us to the ground
state now the speed
at which it would take us to the ground
state depends on the gap
between uh the ground energy and the
first excited state
the larger the gap is the fastest the
faster we will have is
this convergence now if intuitively if
we are converging very fast and we are
starting from something that has no
correlation at the product state
then it also means that the target you
know the point
the fixed point of this of this map
should not have
too much correlation so
so this is one uh
one intuition why would why the
existence of the gap is an important
thing
for uh for establishing an area however
it turns out that taking this intuition
and turning it into a rigorous theorem
is not a very simple thing to do and so
far it has only been
uh established uh generally and
rigorously
uh only in one d and there is uh and
this was
first done by matthew hasting in in a
breakthrough result from 2007 in which
he showed that the
if we had a one-dimensional system so
here it would be just a chain of spins
sitting or cubits sitting
next to each other and there is a local
hamiltonian that acts nearest neighbors
and in this case if we bipartite the
system into two parts so we have
we have the part here and the part here
and we measure the entitlement entropy
between these two parts
then the entanglement entropy will not
depend on the size of the bulk of
of one of these parts it will only
depend on the size of the
of the area of the cut between them and
in
1d it's just a constant so therefore
each
the area low in 1d would imply that the
entanglement entropy should be bounded
by a constant
and this is precisely what uh what
hasting did
sorry here again it should be just delta
e
he showed that the if the local
dimension of the particles is is d
and this and the spectral gap is is
delta
then the entanglement entropy is bounded
by this constant this is the exponential
of
load d divided by the spectral gap
and actually hasting proved more and
from his proof we not only were able to
to bound entanglement entropy but we
could bound uh
also the the other uh
the other schmidt's schmidt coefficient
the other coefficient
in every uh bipartition of the system
and as a result
uh could show
that for uh for for such granted there
is always an efficient
description uh using a polynomial cancel
network in this case it will be this
matrix product sequence one-dimensional
comb-like
tensor network that uh that showed
and as a result the problem is inside
and b
because well we can just give you this
this tensor network is a proof and you
can con you can use it
to do efficient calculations and
convince yourself that indeed
the energy is what uh i claim it is
okay so uh so that was hastings uh
uh breakthrough in 2007 and ever since
there was
a thread of works that that uh improved
improved his uh his result or or tried
to push to
uh more general directions so let me
just
give a very brief list so uh
together with alexekitev and zeph and
and dumash we
we proved in 2013 we
had an alternative proof for the uh for
the
area law using the agst framework which
i will explain uh
soon and um in which the uh
the bound on the constant of the entropy
was
uh was improved significantly so instead
of having an exponential now it is only
a
polynomial of the of the d and the and
the delta
parameters uh another interesting uh
result is by uh
from 2013 and and they showed that
uh at least in in one these systems it
is enough to have some sort of uh
decay of correlations in order to uh to
prove
an area law and um and finally
um zeph thomas vidiq and umesh they
managed to
also to show that the um
in 1d it is not only not only that there
exists an efficient classical
description for the ground state but
that
this description can also be efficiently
found
classically using a polynomial time
algorithm so
that means that the problem of
approximating the ground state is not
only an np but
it is actually in p in 1d
um going on to 2d then here we
still don't have a proof for the general
case but there are some
uh some exceptional things that we can
do
under under further uh assumptions for
so for example uh
tastings and um
uh they proved that uh if if the if the
spectrum has a sub-exponential number of
excitations then one can show uh an
aerial lobe
in more than one d um
we do i'm sorry i don't know how to say
this name oscillator
in 2010 uh they they proved uh an area
law for uh
for a system in which uh diametron
is frustration free and is made of uh of
uh two local
uh spin half systems i will discuss
sorry i will just
uh we'll discuss a little bit further
what the frustration basis are
um mechanically showed that if you have
some sort of idea
of adiabatic assumptions on the path of
hamiltonians then you can also
prove area loss in in higher dimension
and um
cow uh in 2014 use some some sort of uh
local consistency and overlap conditions
between different parts of the system
in order again to establish a 2d airlock
and finally there is this
very recent result that i hope to uh to
get in the end this talk
uh by anubag and uh
david gussett in which we show that if
the system is frustration free
and has another stronger than a gap but
a local gap
condition then we can also prove an
error law
okay so this was the
the first part this was the introduction
for um for what is an area law and why
uh and why it's interesting and now let
me try to explain
one approach for proving the area law
using uh
the approximate lawsuit projection
framework
okay so so let's recall what the problem
here
is that we are trying to to solve we
have uh we have a system
that is defined by uh by a local
hamiltonian
and we we have its ground state
and we have some bipartition of the
system into l and into the
other part of the system and using this
bipartition we can write
most generally we can write down the
ground state as a superposition of
product states
between l and its uh external part
and uh what we this this this
decomposition defines to us
some sort of probability distribution
these are the lambda alpha squared
and we want to show that in some sense
this probability
is is is sharp it's picked on very few
uh on very few values and and and then
it is it decays very quickly
okay so therefore the the
um the entropy of that probability is
is is relatively low so specifically
what we want to show we want to show
that um
morally that the number of of
non-vanishing
coefficients in in in this in this uh in
this state it
scares something like uh the exponential
of the boundary
of the of this region hell
so this is more or less the the mission
that we are set
to solve okay so
um so how can we do that so uh
let's first assume without loss of
general generality that the
ground energy is zero we can always
scale the the energy of the system by
adding a constant
not changing anything so in that case
if we go back to this first intuition
that we have
we can look at this map that takes any
state and and pushes it
toward the ground state by simply by
rescaling
every eigen state in its decomposition
every eigen state which is not the
ground set by scanning it by some number
which is
smaller than one and therefore if we if
we apply it more and more and more times
we get closer and closer and closer to
the browser
now instead of uh instead of applying it
if we want if now if you want to uh to
show an aerial law what we want
to show is that this guy the grassroot
doesn't have a lot of entitlement
so and but every application of this
of this operator here can create more
and more entanglement
it can create more and more
superpositions of parts
from the inside and the outside so
instead of
so one way to proceed is instead of
starting from an arbitrary
product stage let us start with a
product state of
that is made of two states one state is
uh
defined on uh on the on the inside
this will be i1 and once a is defined on
on the outside
and let us start and let the stake as a
starting point
the product state that has the largest
overlap with the ground state
and one can one can show that this is
actually the
the first the first product state in
this in this expansion this uh
schmidt schmidt decomposition and let us
take this state to be the
starting point of of this
of this mapping and see how many time we
have to apply this map before we can
start filling the ground state so
if if o1 if we now try to uh
to expand o1 times i1
in terms of the ground state and
anything that is perpendicular to the
ground state and will be
killed by this map then the overlap
then the the the coefficient between the
ground will simply be the overlap of
this product state for the ground state
which would be
lambda one and the rest
will be something which is by definition
perpendicular to the ground state
therefore um
if we now take this this mapping here
and we applied
l times to the to this product state we
we ought to get
something like lambda one times uh
times the growth state plus some error
that will go down
the more uh the more we apply this map
now this operator here
it is in sense it is some sort of an
approximation
to the projection on the ground state it
is not exactly the projection because it
doesn't kill anything which is
perpendicular to the ground but it
shrinks it a little bit and therefore
it is just an approximate uh projector
and it is this type of object that
we will be you we will be using in order
to establish
an area
okay so how can we use this type of
object so
generally let us assume that we have
this um
this type of some sort of an
approximation to the ground state
projector
and uh and therefore when we
apply it on on on on the product state
with the large overlap with the ground
state o1 and i1 we get
we get this overlap with the ground
state plus some sort of an error
but the question is in order in order
for us to be able to say that this is a
good approximation to the ground set we
have to
to realize how important is this error
here
so this is one question that we we must
first
understand in order to be able to
analyze this state and the other
question is how much entitlement is
there in this uh
in this state we started
with something that has no entitlement
which is a product state but then we
applied this approximate bronsted
projector
and it can create some entanglement
between the inside and the outside so
how much in time we need there
um so to answer these two questions we
need to characterize
our agst and we do that using two
numbers which are called d
and delta and they do precisely answer
these two questions
so so the
okay so first first thing we we
require that uh the hsp
one thing i didn't say but we can now uh
require is that
um it will preserve the ground state so
on the glass itself it acts like exactly
like a protector
it preserves it um and then
in order to uh to characterize how large
is the arrow what we
what we will do we we will use this
parameter
delta that tells us what is the distance
what is the opera
the operator norm of the distance
between our
operator k and the exact ground state
projection
so delta is uh
tells us essentially how good this agsp
how close
is it to uh the ground state projector
and
in order to understand how much
entanglement this this guy is creating
let us uh we define this parameter sorry
define this parameter
sorry
sorry
okay um in order to understand how much
entanglement this guy is creating
let us look at the minimum number of
superpositions of operators that acting
only on on the inside
on the an operator that acts only on the
outside and
let us look on the minimal way in which
we can write k
like that and then
the number of such of such terms in the
superposition will
will tell us um how much entanglement
this uh
this this state uh create because if we
if we act on with this state on the
product state then we will end up having
at most
superposition of at most d product state
so so the two important parameters are d
and delta and uh if we have
such a such a an agsp and we know it's d
and delta then if we act on on on
on some products that would be say gst
then we know that it will give us
it will give us the uh some
it will give us some uh weight on the
ground state plus an error
that um that scales like delta and if we
act on it uh l times then you know
the grass it will remain the same but
the error will keep on
keep on shrinking so now we ask
ourselves okay
so we can now create states that are
getting closer and closer and closer to
the ground state
but how large should this l be in order
for us
in order for this thing to be a good
approximation of the ground
state and
uh and the idea is that for this thing
to be a good approximation to the ground
set what we need
we need that the error which is of order
of delta to the power
should be much smaller than the weight
of the ground state
uh if if we manage to find such delta
then we can write that the ground state
is is is given by this
by this is approximately given by this
formula
and since we know that uh the number of
of product states
in this expression will be d to the
power of l then we know that
the overall entanglement of of the of
the
of the ground state will be will be
bounded
by uh by log of d to the power of
l but the question is uh
what is number because what is number
one because it is exactly lambda one
that tells us how how big this l should
be and this l
exactly tells us what is the um what is
the entanglement entropy of the
of the gram state so without knowing
lambda 1 this is
this old problem is is useless so this
is where um
the bootstrapping dilemma arrives and
this is
this is the actually the the focal point
of this of this approach
and what it tells you it tells you that
if you manage somehow
to find to construct an approximate
branch state projector with
with parameters d and delta that
satisfies this inequality so that the
product
is smaller than one half then this
necessarily tells you that lambda 1
is lower bounded by uh
by by 1 over square root of 2d
and as a result you can you then use
this
this uh this type of argument and there
as a result then you can now prove that
the entanglement entropy of
the concept should be bounded by an
order of of log d
and uh to prove this uh
to prove i mean the proof this of this
theorem
uh can be uh
it is few lines there is some sort of a
sketch here
one way to see it is that you know you
can start from uh from an unintended
state
v which is uh just a product state of
something in the inside
of the the outside and the inside and
apply an agsp
k and you get some state w and uh
now w because you you you
pushed it closer and closer to the
ground so now it has a
larger overlap with the uh with the
ground state
and in addition you know that it is only
made of at most
d product states so
because now d times delta is smaller
than one-half then
you can prove that at least one of these
pieces one of these products that has a
has a bigger overlap than v and and then
you can
go back here and apply it again and
again and this process
will converge and it will converge until
uh the overlap is uh is of the order of
one over two
squared squared of d so this is one way
of showing that
if you have this good agsp with two
with these two favorable uh parameters
then then
you can uh you can prove it area so
what this all tells us is that in order
to
prove an area law all that we need to do
is to
construct an agsp and approximate ground
state projection
with with the
with the good parameters v and delta
okay so
so the the overall plan uh
plan now is uh is first find a good hsp
so find the k with these parameters d
and delta so that the
product is smaller than one half
this will tell us that the entanglement
entropy of this region will be smaller
than
log of d and if it happens that the d
in the in the agsp that we found has a
bond dimension which is only exponential
in the
size of the boundary then we are done
because that will imply
that the tangent entropy is smaller than
the
um than the size of the boundary
but then of course the question is how
can we construct
good agses other end questions so far
okay um
okay so this is the third part of
constructing a good agsps
[Music]
so in order to so now i'll start making
a lot of assumptions and i'll i'll i'll
i'll be even less rigorous than i was
before so uh but this is just in order
to to make things
uh i will try just to pass the
the overall structure instead of
focusing on the beaches
so um i would now first assume that we
are now
uh dealing with 1d systems so
our hamiltonian is defined on a chain
of of cudits sitting on a line with
nearest neighbors interactions like the
interactions i drew here
and we are interested in bounding the
entanglement between the left part and
the right part
i will also assume that the hamiltonian
is frustration free
what this means is it means that um
the terms of the hamiltonian are all uh
are all positive or non-negative
and the ground and the global ground
state of the system is also the local
ground state of each one of these
of this term so it is inside the ground
space of each one of these
of these local terms so that the global
ground state
does not frustrate anyone locally
because it is
every forever for each and every local
term
it is also their private ground state um
so this is where the name the name comes
from
and if we actually assume that we are in
a frustration-free situation then we can
go even further and assume without
losing any general generality that
the local terms here are are just uh
projectors
as far as as long as we are interested
in
in the properties of the ground state
only
so this will be our my assumption of
that the local terms of projector
and in addition i will also assume that
we are locally gapped what that means it
means that if i now look at
part of the system and i look at the at
the hamiltonian of that part so i'm
looking at the sum of the interval
of the of the his that are defined on
the particles in that segment
then also that hamiltonian has
a spectral gap and it is bounded by
below
some constant delta so this is
uh this is the assumption of a local gap
or a uniform gap if you wish
so it means that not only the global
hamiltonian is is as a constant gap
between the
the lower uh the eigen the
ground energy and the thresh but this
happens also locally at every
continuous patch of the system
so having these three uh assumptions let
us now first
let me just remark that for the uh
for the proof of the all these all these
exceptions
assumptions except for the 1d uh
assumption are not necessary
but they will make our life a bit
simpler so
i that's why i included that so
um let's first uh let us do the first
attempt in trying to prove to
construct an approximation for the
ground state projector so
the first and most obvious attempt would
be just to use this uh
good old one minus h to the power of l
this thing uh leaves the glass the
ground state environment and
and it it shrinks every uh every
other eigen eigenstate of the
hamiltonian by
by a small amount
however if we try if we now try to
analyze
what is the uh what are the d and delta
properties of this of this hamiltonian
you will notice that
the delta so the amount of error that we
that happens here is something like one
minus the
the smallest eigenvalue of the system or
the difference between that eigenvalue
and the ground energy divided by
by h to the power of l in other words we
get this
the the the worst behavior happens when
we when we look at the first excited
state
and um and this number is it's pretty
bad because it's not
small at all it's very close to one
actually because
h is the norm of the hamiltonian of the
system it can be
very large it can be of the order of n
and delta can be
quite small it can be 0.1 or something
very small so
all together this thing is not a very
small quantity and on the other hand
if we try to analyze the the d
parameters so how many
how many products take this applying
this this
this operator creates then we can we can
do it by
uh writing h as a as a sum of all the
terms from
all the terms that act on the left side
uh plus all the terms that act on the
right side plus this term here in the
middle
which is called h min and
one can one can easily show that the uh
the amount of uh the amount of uh
entitlement or the number of products
they that are
created this way is huge it is something
like d
squared plus 2 to the power of l and
in all situations this d will go to
infinity much
much much faster than this delta will go
to zero
and as a result d times delta will be
much much much larger than one
so that means that this construction is
is
is not good it's not strong enough in
order to give us
an area okay
are there any questions
okay right
so so let us try something else so
i will now add another ingredient uh to
the
the to the discussion and this
ingredient is called the detectability
level which is
uh some useful lemma that applies for
the ground states of frustration-free
hamiltonians
and essentially what the islamic tells
us it tells us if that if we want to
approximate the projector on the global
system to the ground state
then we actually can do that by
patching together local projectors so we
can divide the system
into segments like you know the five
particles here and the five particles
here we can take the projector to the
local ground space of these particles
and then we can have you know and then
can have a projectile to the
to the uh to the local ground space of
these particles this particle etc
and if we take the product of all these
projectors
then we get an approximation to the
overall to the global ground state
and the quality of this approximation
depends on the overlap
between these um these projectors
so if the if the overlap is of the order
of m
so the radius of the of the overlap then
what the detectability lemma tells us is
that um
and as long as there is a gap in the
system
then it tells us that the product of
these local projectors
sorry is a good approximation to the
ground state
it is it is good in the sense that it is
it decays exponentially
and the error the the difference between
these two operators is the operator norm
decays exponentially
um in the in the
in the length of m so
so we can approximate the global
projector by
small pieces as long as we have a gap
so now we can try and and
and give a second attempt at building uh
an agsp
and the idea is now that if you want to
buy to build an agency that will bound
entanglement
across this particular cut then
maybe what we can do is we can take we
can
write down or approximate the graphite
projection
not by h to the power of l something
like that but instead
make it a product of three projector the
projector to the grass plates on the
left
the ground states on the right and then
a local projector here in the middle
so our candidate now looks like this
projector of three
this product of three projectors
and now but now if we do again this
analysis
we see that this is still no good why it
is not good well
because the delta so this is the error
it will it will it will be just what the
detectability element tells us it will
be something which is proportional to
the to the overlap which would be
of the order of m however
the amount of entanglement because now
the left side and the right side do not
create any entanglement between the left
and right because they only act on one
side
but what creates entanglement is is by
mid
the projector in the middle and because
it is defined on
m on on m qubits
order of n one can
one one can uh one can only bound its
entanglement entropy using
something which is of the order of d to
the power uh two to the
m because it is uh it is supported on on
d
particles and as a result again we're in
in in the same business where uh
for any uh for any realistic
uh in any realistic situation the the
the pace in which d goes to infinity is
much stronger than the pace at which
delta goes to zero and again d delta is
much bigger than one so this
construction
is still not giving us a good a gst
okay so but there is a purpose why i
gave this instruction
and this is the third attempt so in the
third attempt
what we will do is we will look at this
middle guy here
and we will try to tackle this problem
here
instead we will try to replace it with
something that
maybe creates less entanglement
this is what this figure here is try
tries to describe so instead of using
the projector to the local ground state
here in the middle what we will do we
will try to approximate this crosstalk
using some polynomial of the hamiltonian
of the terms in this segment here so for
example we might
try to approximate it using this type of
thing you know using taking
1 minus h middle divided by its norm to
the power of k we know that this thing
again it shrinks everything which is
perpendicular to the to the local ground
state and it keeps
preserve the glasses so it is some sort
of an approximation
to the ground state and as we will see
it also creates less entanglement so
maybe we can use this thing or more
generally maybe we can take
any some sort any sort of a polynomial
that will approximate
uh this the projection
here and it turns out that the best
polynomial that will give that will give
us the best approximation for a given
degree is the chebychev polynomial so if
we want to approximate
the the the ground the projection to the
ground state of the certain of a certain
uh
of a certain hamiltonian the best thing
we can do if we want it
as a function of this uh of this amateur
is simply to use the cherished
polynomial and
the intuition is that the championship
polynomial is in some sense very uniform
so if we scale it such that it will
preserve the ground state
then you can see that because of of the
way it fluctuates then the
it will kill in a uniform it will shrink
in a uniform way
all the energies in in in a certain
range whereas
if we are instead looking at the one
over
something like one over x um
then this uh uh then this thing will
will
will have very uh sorry we'll have um
will have very strong effect on the high
energy but we will not
will not almost will not do anything on
the uh
on the on the on the low energy so
in that sense the charity polynomial is
a is a much better way
of approximating the ground state
and indeed it is used in many places in
approximation theory and also
in in computer science for for
approximating
um step function and
and the projector can be viewed as as
none other than
um than a step function uh
in the in the in the spectral states of
the of
of the hamiltonian so if we if we take
this together then we
uh then you know a chapter polynomial of
degree l we can see that
if we apply it on the amateur if we
rescale it properly and apply it on the
amino and middle
it can give us an approximation of the
um of the of the of the projection to
the
attempt which with this type of error
but then
the question is okay so we did that we
we're now approximating this guy instead
of of using the exact
projector but why how can that save us
how can that give us less entanglement
and here is the second idea
and this is the idea of entanglement
amortization
and the idea is that if we now
look at t to the l of h mean this is
essentially a bunch of terms like that
it's taking this local sums of h i and
taking it to the power of l
and the idea is that this type of
expression creates
much much much less entanglement than
one can naively think and the the reason
why it creates this entitlement
is that if we're looking if we now open
up this expression where we can see that
it will be the product of
of different ages at different different
place
different places and if we uh focus on
one such term
then we can see that there must be one
cut in which there will be
uh in which there ought to be at most
uh l divided by m turns if there is
if if the if the degree is at most l
and the number of times here is uh is at
most m
and so we can always estimate the
entitlement in that cut
and then we can from that from that cut
we can also deduce the
overall entanglement in the middle so
the the overall uh the overall
conclusion
from from this is whenever we have a
power of
of a local hamiltonian the amount of
inductance it creates is much less than
uh than l and in fact it is given by
this
expression here so it is l divided by m
plus m instead of just d to the power of
m therefore if we
take l to be m squared we can get that
the amount of endangerment just it's
just something like m
and um
if we put it all together now we can see
that
uh then the the project the the the
operator the approximate glossary
projector that we get by
taking this local championship in the
middle and and these two projectors on
the
on the on the outside will give us these
two
d and delta and
as a result it will give us uh we can
then play by taking
m to be of this size we can always get
that d
delta x is one f and this is essentially
the way
uh that the area though in one d is
proven
in the 2012 uh
okay are there any questions how much
time do i have
i say i'm sleeping um
i think i think we are
pretty much uh you know it's off to 12
so
it should be you should be close to
wrapping up yeah
yeah just two two more size i guess yeah
so okay so let me just give the very
uh brief idea of how this can be even
further improved
in order to uh prove it to the area law
um
so so you know in one view what we did
we
was to use the charitable and to
approximate the grounds the projector
and it gave us
the this type of approximation and in
order to do better we need a better
aegis
in order to prove the area in 2d and
then you know one natural question to
ask is
whether we can find a better polynomial
than the chapter
so generally we cannot but it turns out
that sometimes
there are some circumstances in which
one can do better and
for for example there is this famous
paper
uh by jeff khan uh nathalina and alex
santoski that says that um
that in the case of uh
of polynomials over beats in or not for
our case
it would be the case where the
eigenvalues of h are integers
then actually we can this instead of
having this type of error we have this
type of arrow so it's like the square of
what what is written here
so it is a much much better thing
and this this motivated us to try and
find
better constructions in stronger
construction
in which we may may be able to imitate
this uh this behavior
um so the idea and this is i'm
really just skipping the idea is
essentially to take what we had before
but
now instead of diluting just par just
one
projector we will dilute all
a bunch of these projectors and we will
look
at the at the detectability level made
of these diluted
or approximate projectors
and as a result there will be much less
entanglement however
because now each one of these
things is not a real projector but only
an approximate to the projector we will
have errors from
different sources so we will need to be
able to take care of errors that happen
at different sources so in order to do
that what we were
what we did was to uh to follow uh the
construction of a robust polynomial
by shuttle that originated from the
problem of
suppose we we have a bunch of noisy
cubits and we want to approximate the
end function of these noise qubits how
can we do it
in an efficient way taking by taking
care of
of different errors that happens in
different places
and it turns out that one can define
such uh such a polynomial
that does this approximation so if every
uh
cubit is a bit noisy so it's not exactly
zero it could be something between zero
and epsilon
then we can still write down a
polynomial a multivariate polynomial so
now it's not a single variable
a multiplied and it will give a very
good approximation of the
of the end function and what we did in
the paper was just to take this
polynomial and try to convert it into a
polynomial in operators and then
apply it to these diluted operators
that make up the agsp
so overall the structure was you know
start with the diluted chapter
polynomials
combine them together using this robust
polynomial
into into larger blocks
and then do this process again and again
and again so what what you get is
some sort of renormalization group flow
so
you you you get bigger and bigger and
bigger
uh uh approximate projectors
and um and it turns out that this
this multivariate uh polynomial
approximation
can actually get you something much
stronger than the plain chapter
polynomial
and in the 2d scenario what we did was
exactly to apply this
this construction along the cut so you
know we have these uh
these guys here uh there are some
overlap together with them
and and essentially this is this is the
uh
the agsp that that could could make the
job
in the in the 2d setup
um so yeah so this is the
the theorem that we were able to prove
and uh
let me just wrap up so in summary uh
let me just say that area laws are the
key to understanding
our key to understanding the completed
computational complexity of many valid
quantum system
and the combination of the approximate
one-sided projective
framework with techniques and results
from
computer science and approximation
theory gives us very powerful tools
to analyze uh the ground state and
ground space in
general low energy states of many body
quantum systems
and of course there are still many many
open questions and many open problems
for example
can we relax the the condition that we
use in the 2d proof
like the local gap or the frustration
famous can make it
a general proof for the 2d case can we
generalize it to 3d or 4d
this is not clear because in some sense
we use the fact that the cut into the is
one dimensional
um and also importantly can we
can we take this result and just like in
the one decades
prove that there is an efficient uh
tensor network
um intensive network that approximate
uh this grant state and uh and finally
can
even if we did that can then be can we
use this sensor network in order to
and contract it efficiently in order to
be able to do calculations with that so
in other words these two things ask
whether we can find efficient
representations also for
for 2d ground states and
i think the grand plan here that is that
if we manage to
to prove this thing then the the the
global picture
would be that uh the complexity
of of this type of systems of of quantum
scenes spin system
the grass the ground state or on the d
dimensional lattice with nearest
neighbor interaction
and a gap then it is a session classical
it will be inside np
it will have it will have a classical
description and efficient classical
description so
so at least from from that point of view
these systems
are in some sense classical
okay so thank you
okay well great thanks um thank you um
let's see if there are any questions
[Music]
robert chook is asking why np
um why np because
then if you if you have an efficient
description i mean if you manage to show
an aerial law
and you manage to show that there is a
tensor network that describes
this these states and you can use this
sensor network in order to do
calculations then this sensor network
it can it can be it can be you know it
can be it can serve as a classical
weakness so
the problem becomes np right oh i missed
the last point sorry
i see okay could it actually be easier
in 3d and 4d
than in 2d because at some point
monogamy should kick in right if you go
to high dimensions you could imagine the
product is easier maybe
yeah i mean proving the area did this
happen or i mean
uh i didn't try but it's a good point
you're right
yeah oh that's very
yeah but but you know i i guess that in
order to prove it rigorously you will
really have to take a very large
dimension
well you could try to approach it from
very high dimensions and maybe you meet
in the middle
whatever excuse you okay
okay
very nice um
[Music]
are there any other questions um
um yeah can i ask um i'm
i'm confused about how strong
this local gap condition
seems to be um
yeah so so i guess um
it's strong enough that we cannot lift
it okay
for the moment um but but our
um do we know of any
um i mean of course knowing of systems
that have gaps in general is hard
um to sort of have a
you know a stable of examples but do we
have
examples where
we know there's a global gap but no
local gap
uh so um
i think andrug is here i mean he is the
wizard of all these
kind of comments so he he has this kind
of an example
are you around oh hey uh so
i don't uh so our assumption is more
like uh
for all the rectangles for squares on
the lattice
uh so for that there are no uh
there are no such examples um but
you can have examples where you have a
square lattice and if you have a tilted
square within the square lattice then
you can
lose the local assumption there
so we don't require such such
sufficients sorry so you know of an
example where if you use a tilted square
you can sort of not have a gap
but yeah so you can have a gap system on
a square
uh but then you have a tiniest square
inside which is
45 degrees tilted then you won't have
local gap there
but we don't use such systems
and
[Music]
this local gap sorry does local local
gap doesn't guarantee global
gap unless you sort of unless local gap
does mean also taking the full square is
that right
or or is that not right
i think that it looks great
in our definition it does i mean we we
we say that every
every region has a as a low as a gap
which is all bounded by this delta
and so also the full region is
absorbable right but if i if i said like
oh i'm only going to allow you to do
that for
squares at as large as three quarters n
would it imply would it imply it would
not imply a global gap condition would
it
uh no so these tilted squares could be
pretty large
and there would still be an issue so
it's more about the alignment of the
square with respect to the larger
square so they have to be well aligned
and then we're fine
so regarding this can i ask if you are
assuming uh if you are assuming that
any sort of subsystem is gapped or just
some structured ones
structures
yeah in the proof we yeah we asked only
for for squares for example
sorry but they're structured with
respect to the boundary that you're
interested in
right yeah but if you if you had a
boundary which was
which was uh at a different you know
different shape then you would need a
different structure
right yeah yeah but
i mean i we believe we believe that this
is uh
this is really a something technical
that can be easily solved i mean
it would not be too hard to generalize
the proof for any shape
right but but then once once you
once you wanted for every shape of the
cut then would you need this local gap
for every
sort of yeah yeah subsystem yeah
okay um
yeah um does this
local gap uh make more sense for
um frustration-free systems or
then i think so yeah i think so because
yeah
because in the specialty system there is
this uh
this good overlap between the ground
states and so it
it makes like more sense i mean i don't
think it's very natural to
to discuss it so actually i think also
the key for for generalizing this
this proof to frustrated system is first
to get rid of the local gap
assumption
so are you saying that there's no no
natural
definition of local gap in once you once
you get trust
once there's frustration yeah i think so
it does it doesn't
i mean if you have frustration why
should you have uh for example why
should you have
uh degeneracy of the ground space
but you must have degeneracy if you have
if you want to have something not
triggered globally right there
must have degeneracy of local parts of
the system
you could i mean you could do something
like insist on
polynomial number of states and a
constant
right in a constant spectrum yeah
yeah yeah maybe yeah maybe that would be
uh yeah
but uh yeah but
intuitively i think you can we can just
get rid of this assumption
somehow i don't know how but uh but
i think the conjecture is true also
without this assumption
ramis and lynn
okay yeah so yeah so just a quick
question so to what extent do you
um need translational invariance or to
what extent
yeah how do you make use of it in your
local hamiltonian
so you could actually just have locality
and no translation in various and
everything should work
but like um i see so
yeah you would expect the transition
variant case to be harder i'm trying to
see
how does it get harder if you impose
transition in variance
well sorry why why would you say that it
would become harder if you're
transitioning violence
uh you know if you for example if you
look at disordered systems
it's possible to have it's easy to see
that they could have
you know disconnected regions that have
no entanglement
so like once you impose translation in
variance things kind of become harder
which is i think the limit that you've
succeeded in
so i don't know i mean in our
non in none of our proof did we ask for
the hematomas to be translational
environments
yeah that's right that's right um
yeah so intuitively i would have thought
no that's good
but intuitively like for translation
variant case
the situation is harder i wanted to see
like
if there was some intuition for why but
but
wouldn't it be easier actually if you
have possession environment i mean
you have more structure in the system in
some sense though i mean
you're more constrained you're more
limited so i i would
i would have guessed that the
you know you you have more handles in
order to to create
a good ats feeds or to to gain some
understanding i mean it would be easier
probably in that sense to analyze the
structure of the system now
well if you have like random iod
interactions for example
and you have a local hamiltonian
then it's not sorry you have random one
suppose you have random local
interactions
all right let's take him to the iid
event like independent identical
distributed
it's not hard to prove that they can
have regents or puddles say rare local
regions
that decouple from the rest of the
system
so in some sense you can make use of
probability theory to make statements
very easy
whereas when you have translation
variance is actually harder in my
experience because of
exactly what you said this extra
structure puts limitations on
what he can use but okay maybe i should
read you a paper more carefully to see
like
you know how you've done it so i'm just
trying to see you know like
how how how things would have become
more difficult i also had a quick
comment about
norbert's uh statement so if you go to
really high dimensions then mean field
theory becomes exact
and you know then then you know they are
trivially everything
things go to a product state so
trivially the area law holds as well
so like these lower dimensional things
two and three
are likely the hardest cases right
yeah it was a very nice talk and also a
very nice tutorial before
thank you guys
um great you know i've put the gathered
sorry was this was there one other
question
on iraq and nilan had had a question
uh yeah one more question um your 3d
your 2d ages p um in the other direction
so
parallel to the cut does it have volume
in sangement
sorry uh does your hsp have uh
full entanglement volume entanglement in
the other direction
say the verb yeah yeah i think yeah
yeah because it it uses um
i mean these bars here are uh
are very non-local so if if you cut it
like that
you might you might have uh
all right thanks thanks for a beautiful
talk thanks
great thank you so i put in um the
gather town link in
um in the chat for anyone who wants to
hang out and talk
talk uh for longer but um
but thanks again uh italian and jeff ah
this was really fun okay thank you
right